his name is Rob Corddry you have seen
him before all the time The Daily Show
Hot Tub Time Machine Children's Hospital
Emmys and of course had the Emmy Awards
Emmys but also ballers to starting this
upcoming Sunday
I love season boilers ballers season and
thank you okay sorry but I like that no
ballers - that's what we are dollars
also welcome back to New York thank you
I hear that you I went on your Wikipedia
page oh good and because that's how we
do big-time research it's all accurate
and it said it said you had two odd jobs
that your security guard at the Met and
you hung out you handed out Mexican
restaurant menus right down the street
from here style where any detail there
was that many details I think it's still
around
it's uh on seventh Avenue or something
and the guy like I would I would take
the flyers and I would throw them away
and go sleep in Central Park right so
cuz that's safe right because then the
boss just started noticing he wasn't
getting any business from these flyers
this aggressive liar business model
right and so he said his solution he
goes when you take it take the top smack
it and then pass it out and say good
Mexican food so this lasted like 10
minutes and then I took a nap this is
episode 71 we always name a famous 71 so
if you have one sorry about with Tyrone
Smith left tackle the Dallas now let's
say Jason Peters Trent Williams and if
Getty Malkin I like that I'm gonna say I
was born in 1971 is that good that does
yes year so we need to get this out of
the way now Sims has been someone that's
going on Boston radio a lot he has
talked a lot about the Tom Brady
deflategate scandal who I have no way
back up I've not heard of this I hear
from my good friend Matt Kemp who works
a police report that I know you talked
to him and he goes hey Corddry big time
Pats fan yeah where are you at the past
two those
the Patriots oh okay okay I love the
Patriots take place yeah where are you
ranking it where are you now in your
process of handling it um can I curse
yes we have great herds thank you
because I'm at the point where I don't
give a [ __ ] right basically I've rooted
for the Red Sox all my life yeah they
weren't a winning team until at least in
my person with my perspective recently
yeah so I'm always rooting for the
underdogs
I love and hating the Yankees I love
being able to root for the bad guys now
like I am a an unapologetic Patriots man
Patriots fans like so you become a
Yankees fan it's just football it's like
exactly right and I grew up here so yeah
you know I have respect for the Red Sox
but Yankee fans are legal Empire oh yeah
that's how Noah is you're right a little
bit yeah yeah yeah but I don't care
maybe they cheated who gives a [ __ ] yeah
we're still gonna beat you the exactly
and still would've beat you regardless
what did we do properly but we think
Belichick is the greatest coach of all
time he's a maniac right I mean I yeah
of course he is yeah of course he is but
he's a he's a psycho I don't think you'd
want to like have him over for dinner
yeah make him laugh you could he would
he's a little more social than people
give him credit for I think I'd be
trying too hard and I blow it yeah you
probably get secre to come in
what would you even say what are your
first question on the ballot is
delicious that's a first complement the
food this is delicious right
he might be shaking it so don't worry
and then I'd say mmm love the house I
love I don't know I blow it for
Belichick he'd be like I don't like this
thing I hate it I thought against the
wall be like so you want order PDA
whenever you one bill it's the right
call he would never even like change his
MO
of what he's and you can't fluster bill
really like if you were like throwing
food around back this sucks bill would
just sit there and observe and be like
we're on to Cleveland yes we're on to
the next wave one just like rock right
nice nice so you just came for the New
York Times and you worse no big deal
everybody wants to know about the rock
is it become like a big part of your
life people asking you about the rock
yeah yeah all the time varying degrees
of of embarrassment when they do some
people are like okay first question I'm
gonna ask you this what's the rock like
and then there are people that are like
I bet you everybody's asking about what
the rocks like right but they still want
then they go but then they're like so
what's he like
so yeah so he's cool like what the thing
that's so funny is talk about a person
that puts out there they're like
personal life on all forms of social
media you pretty much know what he's
like because he's showing you everything
right that's what I don't get that's why
people I think that's why people ask
because they're looking for a seam you
know they're looking for they're for the
cat they want you to say he's truly an
ass there's no yeah that's exactly one
like that's all an act
yeah he's putting it on and he's
appealing all genres you were saying
earlier he's the new Arnold he's into
Arnold Mike Arnold Bluhm happy days well
no not only from happy to see you're
dumping your son like that this is a
young bleacher report crew Oh 1971
birthday come on yeah don't do that to
yourself
can we talk about happy days at some
point
Schwarzenegger I was thinking about it
without you know that is right right a
guy he's a politician but my kids love
them in the what's the movie where he's
on the weird island and there's all
these huge creatures the wrong no but
doing this huge bugs they're like this
I'm biking underneath the rock the
movies and he made two of them his name
is Dwayne I know what I call him the
rocks it'll come to me whatever they're
good movies up my kids off of the big
bugs yeah
mysterious island or Mystery Island
either way who cares it's a terrible
name for a movie
think it's that high so I've just got
back from a bachelor party this past
weekend in Austin and I don't know how
I'm function how you do it my body's
sore dude okay little knockerball a
little Botox
how old are you I am thirty just okay so
you're still able to recover you can
recover from them I was saying this I
said yeah guys I'm interviewing rob
corddry on Monday and they're like oh
man we would love to get mr. Rob Corddry
and that's the other thing I thought of
is if you if you went to Vegas I can't
imagine the amount of people going dude
you gotta get just a great place to be
but be going i'll take photos of people
it's like unless I'm with my kids that's
the only time I don't do it or sign up
but when people say like hey man let's
do shots do this shot but I'm like no
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it
I will drink a smart glass of white wine
with you yeah something without any
sulfites cuz that's gonna get me
tomorrow yeah because that's you know I
think people realize the creepiness of
being handed alcohol that you didn't see
get pores deigning wow that's funny you
know what like yeah I don't even I guess
I just do Red Sox fan from gosh knows no
drug if you want to know what it's like
to film that show though just I really
enjoy a lot of personalities of course
Dwayne Johnson even the athletes that
you have on interacting like and they're
good right yeah they really are it's
been a lot of cool most like Entourage
for the NFL that's six I mean I've seen
some of the highlights you know for the
commercials on HBO and stuff of that
like wrestling Terrell Suggs and yeah
yeah were there any other cool moments
you thought in filming that's kind of
stuck out to you but the thing is like
the whole thing is pretty fun I I got to
make my like boiler room Glengarry Glen
Ross speech you know Coffee is for
closers like that is one of the best
scenes it's probably the best scene I'd
say so I thought it's Alec Baldwin's
only seen that movie not in the play
yeah you know
heeey so I got I had you know it's that
moment it's a trope where get out there
and you say hey everybody listen up and
nobody listens up and you have to be an
[ __ ] to get their attention right and
then prove that you're in charge it's
just the best yeah it's the best we like
to talk about when you see NFL players
are funny the big ones are absurdly big
the quick ones the quarters and wide
receivers yeah I'm always taken aback at
how small they are
we had Byron Jones near last year and he
left we're like I don't think he's gonna
make it amazing year
I know songs has been on the show jpp
and Daniel Brown who caught your
attention about how big or how small
they were funny Victor Cruz is very
normal
Suggs has got a booty that is
unbelievable and I mean personality to
men about it I know he does he's got a
large personality yes yeah I know that's
dude I don't know I'm sure you've gotten
to be around a lot of athletes in your
day as it is but not really no no no no
this is my this your first again we're
athletes on Children's Hospital
yeah weird anything stick out to you
about the athlete since we talked about
sports that you know are they more are
they loud big bigger mouth and you
thought are they a little more humble
depends depends on the guy Suggs is let
you know he's never yeah he's in yeah
Anisa good like he improvises he's
always he's so comfortable what this is
the way I they're always very good
that's what surprised me the most right
all of them across the board they're
very good right and I think what it is
is their job is so hard and so dangerous
that when they get in front of the
camera they're like they're not
intimidated no they're not scared
they're not afraid so they're like
they're loose and their belief their
fall was believable yeah it's really
cool yeah that's good that's cool to
hear I think the thing that I've really
been enjoying about the show is there's
no holds barred you haven't let the
party on the yacht and just getting
absolutely Android and like you got the
drugs all that stuff it's it's a solid
HBO show and I think we're at an
interesting time where HBO is far and
away the number one place I would want
if I was an actor or to work I feel like
those shows if it lasts for a long time
he said your company guy we're a Time
Warner family here so you know it's the
I mean to get that and you think about
where you started is that has that been
a cool path for you to let's look back
at all yeah HBO is like getting on an
HBO show is is an honor in itself right
because it does it is a font in ya place
I mean like Tony Soprano yeah and look
at like they don't let up either like
Game of Thrones and did two weeks ago
yes
and this their new show started last
night dollars is starting next week they
always have something great show has
always been good with that hello is go
and want like they watch it when it's on
which is crazy for television right
alright so I know you probably learned a
lot during your time in UCB and I can
imagine that you learned an immense
amount doing the daily show that was a
lot of like I mean there was a really
strong comedy places to learn what did
you learn about comedy I'm gonna get
real deep in the weeds what did you
learn though about being funny but being
a good comedian like what did you learn
from those two places okay the main
thing that the UCB teaches that at first
I didn't really understand it until I
had to put it into practice was like
their their first rule of course is yes
add recess until you agree with it and
add to it right
the second rule at least as I heard it
was always try and make your scene
partner look good
don't worry about yourself worry about
your scene partner you make your scene
partner look good you will look good by
default you know so it's kind of like I
see comedy as the best comedians are the
best a loopers they just toss up the
ball for someone right right get the
glory you know and I know the
quarterbacks I wit the lawn the
receivers better how can you more sports
analogy yeah hey you're deep what about
the daily show what did you learn from
the daily show I learned I start it's
where I started learning how to write I
think watching Jon Stewart like just
take a new story in the morning and then
slowly in craft jokes over it over the
course of a day for presentations yeah
that night like hours later and how that
joke would change and watching him like
watching him change it and and trying to
get into his head trying to think like
you start writing and you start thinking
how what's Jon gonna change about this
right and you know you start to get an
idea but there's guys like Jon Stewart
who they're on a different level so but
I think with that too that I think is
the most intimidating part about comedy
or anything is trusting that you're
gonna create it's going to be judged but
you're gonna be okay putting it out
there and doing it in one day like that
that is wild it's wild man it's live to
tape to so meaning we like we do the
whole thing it's taped you know four
hours before it airs but we do the whole
thing in one shot like very rarely do we
go back to fix like The Sims and left go
podcast that's what we do to revive the
corner Jon Stewart's and then left go
guys you know what my writing skills are
right all right all right just before
you get too deep done good just like
just always imperious with actors and
you always seem like you're having fun
really whenever I see you on the camera
but like when you have party scenes in a
movie do you guys actually ever like
drink or party like in any of your old
movies or the show ballers any of that
do you guys do that a little sometimes
it depends now if I'm on a show where we
have weird self-driving right we have to
drive ourselves to and from there very
very strict about it okay but if we're I
was up and shooting a hot tub one the
first one right we were up in Canada and
up there it's even more lacks and it's
all up to the props Department okay and
they were like you guys one real beer a
fake beer for this one yeah we're like
yeah what do you hear
so we would during some of those days
just get hammered oh shoot how does a
work go when you do it make it better or
does it take note I say fine I have fun
you know you're you're not as you know
your loser but but yeah there was
probably guys on set that didn't like
we're just making up lines by that boy
that's right so there's some people that
need things to get them to an altered
state and then there's someone like Jay
Glazer who I feel like doesn't need
anything
what was your take just on his energy as
a person because I find him to be a
bowling ball of just just I was gonna
say unavoidable rage but it's not anger
no it's just like an exhibition crash
yes that guy loves his job man yeah he
does yes so he he's he's yeah he'll talk
to talk about anything yeah he will and
then really is gay but then he'll go
like halfway through her sentence he'll
go yeah so anyway hold on he's breaking
news he's a funny dude
so yes have you always wanted a Patriots
fan when did you start becoming a
Patriots fan like from birth no I was
never I wasn't a football fan until
about 10 years ago and I I kind of liked
I mean and this is holds true to this
day like there's a group of teams I like
and a group of teams I don't like for
whatever reason I'm sure and and of
course the Patriots are always in the
group of likes but I just gradually just
really started falling into it like
because so I'm I'm more of a football
fan than anything but uh but I love I
love Boston I love Boston sports I agree
it's amazing and I love the energy there
yeah I lived in Boston for awhile and I
love that what's amazing is that sports
as a sports town it's just this is
nothing like the only place you can go
to the dog park and the women are
talking about a sports as much as the
men I'd be like
the wind react man we got a trader on
don't I'd be like why really having this
conversation with like a Ron don't Kim
you can't shoot it get him out of here
oh my god off to the havoc he likes to
make fun of you my horribleness there
that was good I like that whenever
someone's trying to do a Boston accent
they say Javed Yad yeah it forces you to
try the hard thing is to get fit the
arts in because they'll take ours out of
certain words and put them like other
words like hey yeah like what do you
want what are you gonna do I'm gonna go
and get some pizza with Linda how did
you lose it our third Carter is a farmer
who sells purple earthworms at the
airport wow that was a good one think
about it Boston yeah everybody the rock
or anybody that I grew up not him who
else name somebody else I probably
lifted weights for them you probably did
yeah what about Adam left oh no no right
he does it well how much you think I can
bench not a lot
you're probably right yeah save it red
lawyer okay I'm gonna say you know you
can probably go 155 good 185 it's right
for a guy that hasn't done in a long
time it's pretty good I'd be proud of ya
yeah I'll give it a try well that's
gonna tear lies man I don't know what do
you got it let's do know I mean you've
got you filming anything else um right
now I just I guess Chad finished
shooting a movie right in Atlanta called
office Christmas party it comes out
around Christmas right and and then when
that wrapped I just I just decided to
like free time yeah I mean if I get
asked to do something I'll can you know
consider it I'm not I'm not being that
protective about but I'm just like I go
home and I all right wake up and I get
my kids off to camp and then I I take a
nap maybe read the paper this is amazing
when do you start when do they come back
to you and go okay let's start thinking
it's my wife would be the first one I
want to get a pool want to get you out
of the house exactly but that will have
voids that after the season always just
because you know which were the football
players to be available to film the show
a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah we
start in October
okay operation okay interesting thing
when you're doing characters I imagine
some people only know you for those
characters we were talking about the
whole old school before and how awesome
that was the file everybody knows me my
character from old school
well that one guy behind Luke Wilson yes
a guy like this I wrote an article I
dunno I'm gonna blank I'm choking under
the pressure his character your
character with you know your honor your
wife she's checking her dress out and
you're like that was our Lee Brothers
movie what the heck was that I know I'm
like oh heartbreak heartbreak heartbreak
okay that was I always liked those
scenes as well but she comes out and
shows her stuff and you go yeah I wanted
to I had this like awful hair pattern
right then I had this tuft is that what
that's called I call it a tuft and I
don't know I mean Wikipedia I'm not sure
what it's technically love his hair hair
by London that is a bad man I wanted to
I've got to get rid of this and then for
that they were like no keep it keep it
we'd written bits for it I was like
right you written jokes because you
think it looks so stupid okay fine yes
yeah now that I'm just gonna call it
hair Island yeah awful place to get
stranded you ever get called by your
character names within public or do you
get a lot of it so I get a lot of that
but if anything it's usually Lou it's
easy to say Lou but it sounds like boo
sometimes if it's a lot of people are
saying it's really he'll be at the
airport it's like these five dudes
booing me okay and but no no usually
it's like hey I'm uh Phil such-and-such
who didn't do did we go to high school
together I'm like I don't know we
probably I just have a they just can't
place it
yeah cuz I'm that guy sort of I have a
very comfortable level of celebrity
that's well what I think the concept of
anonymity people take it for granted
because then once you start doing stuff
like this
yeah walking through the airport it's no
fault not fun anymore it doesn't mean if
I'm it depends on your mood though right
I mean like my kids yeah I don't engage
I don't you know yeah I just don't want
them to like cuz kids will they'll
inflate it or possibly I just don't want
them to even think about it my kid is
actually enough I have a 10 year old and
a 5 year old my little boy is in the
process right now of he likes to tell
everybody who his grandfather isn't Who
I am not that I'm big deal yeah but my
father still said it
yeah do you know my dear granddad is
phil simms have you ever heard of he'll
just drop that just drop see your let's
eat him on the wall we got a girl and
he's like snow that's what he does it he
does the grown ups which is even worse
but he's seen it so he's seen some
people as of late come up to my dad in
public and he started to put all this
together now so he thinks it's
interesting but it's so embarrassing
what my dirt what my girls know my girls
think basically they just know because
they see billboards from Children's
Hospital up and they're like there's the
clown again called the clown but nothing
and then they'll but I think they think
I only do raunchy stuff which is for the
most part true right not by design but
uh it's uh but and they so they're like
they don't like raunchy comedy they know
they're like very they're like oh my my
dad tells dirty jokes or a link either
you like do you know my brag about me I
went oh man that's why I love this role
though for you because I was watching
ballers in the beginning of every people
like what do you think of ballers I was
like you know I think it's pretty good I
was like obviously I think like the rock
Dwayne is is this is like something he's
made for yeah I was like but Corddry has
always been someone that I've loved from
The Daily Show because he's always had
this hard punch line where it like kind
of hits you in the face and I love
your character because it's it's what
all of us would want to do it Joe is if
we really didn't give a [ __ ] and we're
just kind of like let's just go hang out
the rock and like get really messed up
and get some new clients like really
cool role I based it off a friend of
mine who's that guy I think everybody's
got this guy and they're in their group
of friends like who can go all weekend
doesn't get hung over
yeah right doesn't feel guilt I was just
from this weekend maybe a little
socially weird yeah you know doesn't
under says the wrong damn what's right
on a certain degree but but he'll also
like he's there's so much fun to be yeah
I don't we came like that myself this
weekend I'm a little hurting today I
think we're all hurting I'm hurting uh
we live it where you're going now from
here you went to New York wasted you're
gonna what good for you
I uh I uh I'm gonna do a radio show
going to a radio show all right it's all
downhill yeah I know I think you may
have set the record for most fist bumps
with six five fist bys he could have
been like I love orange juice you like
OJ put him in a headlock cuz he's a Red
Sox fan and I want to get give him a
noogie on hair island come on it was
awesome Rob Corddry ballers season 2
starting this Sunday of course check
that out if you want to go I don't know
get a blu-ray of old school check out
Children's Hospital on Adult Swim and
then his personal phone number we're
gonna put on the bottom of the screen
hit him up he would love to hear from
you so uh Russ Hill classic me nine one
seven 500 it's a New York number yeah
how you're cheating on Massachusetts oh
come on I lived in New York for 15 years
okay I have one last question I know you
have to go do you go so I had a bachelor
party where I saw a guy that I've known
since I was two yeah and a lot of times
when I hang out then they'll be like you
know so like what's this guy like what's
that guy like when you do you ever get
around your old guys and what are those
conversations like cuz I'm sure they
just pepper you know they're pretty like
they're they're I'm more interested in
in there
lives because they all have really
interesting like one of our friends is a
state trooper in Massachusetts and he's
got way better stories than I do like
he's an undercover narcotics Wow trooper
and so like we don't need they don't
need stories about right that's so funny
you know celebs they really crazy we
could have knocking down doors like oh
my gosh way more fun unreal alright he's
gonna go play some pokemons go it's
really hot right now it's dangerous it's
not I'm really into it yeah just don't
go under like the highway and start
looking for Charizard zorse oh [ __ ] crap
oh yeah I just heard about this tiny -
yeah yeah you're not a big fan of course
not I mean we have not a big Pokemon fan
I'm not a big I'm sick of I'm sick of
walking around New York City but the
people like this oh wait there's a car
coming
oh I'm in the middle of every struck me
is a big like Japanese anime fan in
general and maybe especially in Pokemon
yeah that's weird yeah it was weird I
don't read people there's a pleasure be
good thank you get with us you're
allowed to just walk off you don't even
worry Oh hold on let me get my mic